there's some amazing guest stars on the
show including your husband Wells yeah I
mean uh my husband I mean he loves
Play-Doh right I bet like you guys have
some stack now oh yeah oh yeah we have a
lot of Play-Doh at the house now you
know I just talked to him recently and I
asked Mom I was like are you still
coming down from the wedding he's like I
guarantee the repeat guest from The
Wedding who are still hungover yeah he
was like yeah people were turning up
yeah they were turning up it was um you
guys do quite a party we threw a great
party what else and I keep saying we
wish we were guests at our own wedding
that's what he said literally he told me
that
it's true I mean how is newlywed life
it's amazing I mean we're both like
really busy of course so um it's just
really fun I actually like had like a
doctor's appointment the other day
everything's fine but I'd like to check
up and stuff and it was the first time
where I got to like check the married
box on the forms was that like surreal
oh my God because we've been engaged for
three years before we got married so you
know you have the ring on your finger
and you're like really want to check
that box we're supposed to be but here
by now but um it's it's really great he
doesn't feel any different other than
his ring I think
um but for me I was like I feel like a
grown-up now I've I I don't know what it
is animals is like I'm so happy that
like marrying me makes you feel like a
woman I was like well that's not that's
not you're like now you're putting words
in my mouth no I felt like a woman
before now I just feel like a grown-up
that's right a grown woman I like that a
lot well I just told you we just caught
up wells and I and I asked him a very
specific question I was like obviously
you and Sarah have been together for so
long what's one thing that fans would be
surprised to learn about her and we have
his answer for you right here oh
she's like into like witch stuff she's
like a like a witch witchcraft she's
kind of into witchcraft she is a bruja
but she's like legit like
she like I don't she like Burns Sage
things around me and like I feel better
afterwards I'm into it I believe in it
okay Scorpio season got a little crazier
I love it she's and yeah we got crystals
all over our house yeah Halloween kind
of wild at your house then Halloween is
always Wilder house have you seen all
her costumes we always win Halloween wow
Wells married a witch I love it yeah
okay I meant that with Love by the way
but I love it yes
also do you love how he was wearing the
black magic shirt with the cat on it
that I actually bought your impact that
is your impact right there okay so
spooky season is like your your peak
season it's like your Time season I love
it I mean it's it's year round it's not
just spooky season for me but um yeah I
mean my mom taught me how to read tarot
cards when I was a kid and and she does
that as well and I'm very into astrology
it's Eclipse season right now so baby
what does that mean
it's just like
chaotic energy I don't personally
manifest or do any rituals during
Eclipse season okay and it's like a fast
track to like what will be will be
a little bit Growing Pains
I feel like Sarah you have the funnest
gig right now in America because I used
to be obsessed with Play-Doh me too for
you I was obsessed yeah I wasn't as
talented as these kids but I was
obsessed with Play-Doh these kids are so
insane first of all talk to me about how
the opportunity to hosts the family
Plato competition came to be it just
kind of fell in my lap and I said
I really want to I just
um a I love kids I have a lot of nieces
and nephews and um Plato is just so much
fun it's so nostalgic isn't it the smell
it's the smell smell it we have some
right here you guys literally it's
brings me back to myself I feel like
you're like four years old again like as
a parent this is you need this in your
life I just it's it's so funny that it's
called Play-Doh squished because when I
was a kid all I would do would be Sniff
and squish like not to age myself but
before there were iPads we were playing
with stuff like this you know like this
occupied our time I'm just saying really
so fun though are you having a blast
doing it oh my gosh it was so much fun
um we have like the most amazing kids on
the show and adults and the challenges
are like out of this world it's a little
bit like there are some portions of
challenges where it kind of feels like
double dare as well yes so it was really
nostalgic nostalgic for me to film and
it was just it was so fun and just to be
able to like really feed your inner
child you also have a reunion on the
show with your TV mom right Julie Bowen
um how much do you and your cast mate
stay in touch obviously they were at
your wedding yes we we stay in touch a
lot or as much as as we can with all of
our schedules
um it was so much fun to have Julie on
the show we hadn't seen each other in
like a year I think before that
um so it was actually like really hard
for everybody I I kept having to put my
executive producer cap on and hosting
Kat Von because I was like wait a second
we have to like we are working on kids
times right now like Julie and I have to
stop talking and catching up oh my God
you're right because you're like wait
there's a show that we need to produce
that we need to produce yeah and their
kids and they're under a certain age
when you can only have them a certain
amount of hours we need to stop talking
hopefully you can bring her into the
full though and what you're doing oh
yeah it was great I mean I've known her
kids since I mean I've known the twins
since they were in her right
um and so it was just it's amazing it's
crazy seeing her kids grow up they're so
big
I'm feeling very old I did short next to
them but you know that's how I feel
about watching the kids in a modern
family y'all are grown up now it's so
amazing right they're like actually your
siblings now I feel like oh for sure I
definitely view them as my little
brother and my little sister I love that
well this isn't your only hosting gig
you also hosted love Island this past
season I'm so curious like how invested
did you get into not only the couples
but really the drama of it all too I'm
sorry investing
oh my god
um no I was so invested and like I have
a group chat with my friends and they
were texting me nonsense like every day
after the episode would air they're like
oh my gosh I can't believe and this
person and then that they said that are
you kidding me she should leave him
right now and I was like you guys I feel
the same way I was like fangirling at
home because I wasn't at the Villa every
single day and so of course I would
watch every night and just I was so
invested yeah in a lot of those
relationships now did you have to pick
Will's brain a little bit when it came
to like navigating the reality dating
show world I think he was just like I I
didn't necessarily go to him for advice
it is very it is very different and I'm
very much more removed than he is
um in his role
um but he was just like listen listen to
them yeah and just like if they ask you
for advice give the best advice as you
possibly can but just like listen like
that's all that they really need
absolutely are you glad you didn't have
to make margaritas for them at the Villa
like Wells did a Bachelor in Paradise I
I mean I actually do like bartending
like I tend to make drinks a lot at home
like Wells won't make the old Fashions
and I will make the Margaritas cranberry
margarita oh the cranberry Margaritas
right okay I heard about it you said
you're really good at that so actually
you should have maybe mixed up a couple
of cocktails maybe next yeah maybe next
season I'll do like an Ode to my husband
I thought you're not busy though because
you also have a new peacock Series right
that uh spins off the Pitch Perfect
films I mean what can you what do you
want fans of the movies to know about
what you guys have done with this series
oh my goodness I mean we have a lot of
like little Easter eggs from the films
in the show which I think that they
would really like and appreciate and we
really just focus a lot on character
development and friendship and we have a
lot of areas of female friendship in the
show as well as just a human to human
connection and how other people can like
help another person grow within
themselves and evolve to be a better
person and and all of that and then of
course we have like the most amazing
songs and numbers and of course you
gotta have that gotta have that and just
like a beautiful amazing shots of Berlin
we started some of the most beautiful
places
um it was amazing to see all the
architecture and experience it was cold
but I bet it's worth it what was it like
reuniting with your Modern Family love
interest Adam DeVine oh my gosh it was
so good I love Adam so much I mean I've
known him for over a decade I've known
his wife Chloe even longer and I just
love the two of them so much so it was
it was really a dream for Adam and I to
be able to work together again
right exactly we wanted more time to see
you guys on Twitter right now do we get
to hear you sing on this show oh yes yes
you do okay you do it was one of the
biggest reasons why I wanted to do it I
hadn't sung for a job in a really long
time I think probably
I really think the last time I did one
for a job was when I did hair at the
Hollywood Bowl and that was like 2004 it
was a long time ago yeah so um so yeah
it was just it was so much fun to be
able to sing they're like might be a
dance number or two okay
um and I take that stuff very seriously
come from a Broadway background right so
I was like we have to do this and it's
perfect I mean between Pitch Perfect and
Play-Doh you really have a couple of
dream jobs I'm going to tell you that
right now it's amazing well thank you so
much for being here today we appreciate
you and you guys come on yeah it doesn't
get better than this all right what
what's better than squishing Play-Doh
tell everyone am I right when they can
and how they can find the show it's on
freebie November 11th we have an episode
out per week and oh look it's no mess
kids all right no don't worry it's no
mess we really just hope that um
families are able to watch this show and
bring Plato and Artistry into their
homes and their lives Sarah thank you so
much take this home with me though thank
you squish it
foreign